I have for you today maybe the most
depressing education-related story other
than the fact that Betsy DeVos is the
education secretary obviously but short
of that this is pretty embarrassing a
guy who not only believes Noah's Ark the
Noah's Ark story literally but also
believes that dinosaurs were on Noah's
Ark has been hired by Arizona
superintendent Diane Douglas to review
evolution teaching standards which is
the wolf guarding the henhouse in some
way maybe that's not the best metaphor
or analogy but seems like a pretty apt
one his name is Joseph Kazu Lee Diane
Douglas doesn't have much time left a
superintendent in Arizona and she
selected casually to lead a working
group which is going to review the
state's new science standards on
evolution and he is probably the last
person that you want doing that he
number one disturbingly teaches biology
at Arizona Christian University he
believes that there were dinosaurs on
Noah's Ark and that the ark had
obviously plenty of space for two of
every kind of dinosaur and he is
according to a report about him in the
phoenix new times quote a staunch
believer in the idea that enough
scientific evidence exists to back up
the biblical story of creation so I
don't think I have to tell you this but
the superintendent has been trying to
weaken the standards for teaching
evolution and pushing to add biblical
creationism to science classes and
bringing in Joseph Kelly is a great way
to make more of that happen number one
they've already removed the word
evolution itself in countless instances
from the course material and now they're
going to try to make it official the
other thing that they've been doing also
is changing the wording around evolution
so that instead of saying that evolution
is the long established and accepted
scientific explanation for the diversity
of living organisms on planet Earth
which it is they instead say that it is
an explanation implying of course that
there are competing and importantly
equally good explanations which
coincidentally come from the Bible
there's another quote from his interview
in the phoenix new times where he said
quote i'm not saying to put the bible
into the classroom although the real
science science will confirm the bible i
do blame the superintendent here of
course right like she made the decision
to hire this guy but there's a bigger
picture problem here which is that
voters keep electing politicians that
either participate in this stuff or look
the other way when it happens if we had
zero tolerance for this garbage in
arizona or anywhere everywhere that
there's a city council all the way up
through the US senate this would not
happen right superintendents like
douglas would be out and they wouldn't
last long enough to appoint someone like
kelly to be making decisions about such
important things as science standards so
of course it is the fault in this
particular instance of diane douglas the
superintendent in arizona but if people
actually voted more often embarrassingly
low voter turnout in this country we
might be able to solve this systemic lee
sort of from the ground up and that
means that everybody in arizona needs to
vote out every single elected official
who either supports or is indifferent to
or complicit in this nonsense which is
also not going to happen but there are
also voters that believe this stuff
which is another problem and it becomes
this kind of self-fulfilling prophecy of
ignorance you have ignorant people who
go out and vote for ignorant or at least
indifferent to the facts politicians who
then allow education standards to
produce uninformed kids and students who
then become adults start voting and vote
for the exact same nonsense and that's
the vicious cycle that needs to be
broken you need some kind of hard stop
you need some kind of intervention to
stop this period i don't know what the
catalyst has to be but there is a cult
of ignorant
in the united states i've as you know
been spending time in europe over the
last few weeks and i can assure you that
people here are acutely aware of it and
this anti intellectualism that's wound
itself into and kind of wrapped itself
around the political and cultural
institutions of the united states is a
massive problem and i don't know how you
excise it it's easy to say we'll vote
them all out ton of voters like this
stuff ton of voters want biblical
creationism taught in science class so i
genuinely don't know what step one needs
to be